We are here with Jessica Biel
and Melanie Lynskey who star in the new Hulu series, Candy.
It is so epic.
Okay. Now, before you go, if you don't mind,
will you play my favorite game with me?
Some rapid fire questions for both of you?
Totally, yes.
All right. It's time for the final five.
(audience cheering)
All right.
Melanie, I'm starting with you.
And then Jessica, you're gonna answer as well.
Okay, Melanie,
who was the last person you creeped on social media?
Oh my God.
Honestly, probably Celeste Barber.
Do you know Celeste Barber?
Oh, I love her.
She's the greatest comedian.
She's Australian, and she's going on tour.
I love her.
Oh, she's so funny.
Good one to creep.
Jessica?
Cooking with Fiona, Pasta with Fiona,
something this incredible cook that makes
these insane pastas with vegetables that look like art.
I've never seen anything like this in my life.
It's unbelievable.
I was like, maybe I'll get my kids to eat this
'cause it looks so insane.
Okay. I'm already gonna do a list on the show website,
thedrewbarrymoreshow.com,
I'm gonna put all these recommendations.
Celeste Barbara, Pasta Fiona.
Okay. Melanie, is there a bad habit you have
nobody knows about?
Oh, I guess reading the comments.
(Melanie chuckles)
Oh.
Like if there's- yeah.
Honest. I like it.
That is a bad one.
Jessica, same with you.
Bad habit.
I eat and drink coffee
in the shower and the tub
and my husband can't stand it.
(audience chuckles)
That is interesting because I feel
like that is the one place my appetite is curved.
(audience laughing)
Not me.
(Melanie laughing)
Because I'm just trying to do so many things
at once so quickly.
Oh, God.
I just love it so much, though.
Don't open up that Pandora's box for me.
This is the only- this is the only safe zone.
Okay. Melanie, top song on your phone right now on repeat.
Oh, gosh.
My daughter still just only wants to listen
to Gwen Stefani's vision of Jingle Bells.
(audience laughing)
I love that.
Why wouldn't she?
Jessica, song right now that you love.
Song that I love?
Well, I can't stop listening to Groove Theory, "Tell Me".
I mean, that's what I listen to all the time
in the car by myself.
Melanie, first celebrity crush?
My first celebrity crush was Oliver Platt.
(Jessica laughs)
Oh, interesting.
It's my like old time, yeah.
And current celebrity crushes would be Dave Grohl
and Gail Simmons from Top Chef.
Oh my God, I'm so hot for Gail Simmons too.
Oh my God.
Yes
There's never been anyone sexier.
She's the most beautiful face.
Like oh, this unique features.
Okay Jessica, first celebrity crush?
I mean, that was such an interesting answer, Mel.
Mine's probably, you know, Jonathan Taylor Thomas,
like old school.
J.T.T.
(audience clapping)
(Jessica laughs)
Bought magazine 16. I love it.
That's right.
Bringing me back.
Oh, yeah.
(audience clapping)
You guys, I love you both so much,
in life, in your art,
as humans, as women, as mothers,
as women who are trying to do it all
and keeping it super real about it.
I just appreciate you endlessly.
You can catch Jessica Biel and Melanie Lynskey
in the finale of Candy airing on Hulu tonight.
It's one of the best shows I've seen
in as long as I can remember.
You guys are so good in it.
Thank you so much for putting this out there in the world.
(audience cheering and clapping)
Thank you.
Love you.
Love you. Love you, Mel.
Love you so much.
Love your, kisses.
(soft upbeat music)